my next guest has done a lot uh many of
you may know her as uh phyllis from mary
tyler moore show but she can be
currently seen as granny in the beverly
hillbillies movie
please welcome cloris leachman
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
now that is an entrance that is an
entrance
well thank you i think that should be
required of all my guests now
come out do a jig move back even if you
don't want me to because i
have to see you what are you doing
everything's perfectly planned
stop no i can't see
oh that's fine how are you doing
griffin used to do that i thought it
would just lie down on the couch and
talk to him this way
with my head there whatever is most
comfortable for you the most comfortable
everything you want see you
oh well you look very nice tonight thank
you how do i look forget it i'm sorry
sorry very uh no no don't there's no
backup
say how do i look how do i look you look
wonderful all right yes thank you very
much
you could have slammed me but you didn't
i appreciate that
why would i want to do that to you i
don't know some people are mean and
cruel
i'm just filling you in yeah they are i
mean they they had slam books when i was
in sixth grade
and you studied them mine was either
shrimp freckles
and the best was cute but silly and and
out of silly
came this tremendous comedienne
world-famous
[Laughter]
we'll get you a real cigarette if you
want i forgot my blouse is supposed to
go under here so i'm going
i'm going to be very if if it shows too
much just go of course
anyone feel free just just during the
course of the show
and i'll know let me ask you about this
beverly hillbillies movie it's coming
out right now
is it is it out right now at this moment
wait i'm still thinking about this part
where do i get to
all right beverly hillbillies yes
beverly hillbilly is this coming out
yes let me ask you about this i mean we
lie all the time about what day we're
doing the show is this the right day
this is the right day yeah this is all
real
what day is it everything about the show
is real except my hair you know
it's made of polyurethane everybody um
but uh it's coming out and i was gonna
ask you you play the role of
granny in the movie and now you say that
you had never seen the beverly
hillbillies before
is that right right but you you've never
seen the movie before
i mean you've seen the movie you've
never seen the tv show i mean uh
i flick by it it's really a boring
answer though i mean i can tell it to
you because i'm a big fan of the tv show
i'm just surprised
he but i just was cooking dinner washing
dishes during those hours
right and when you finally did see it
you did you like it because i did
i did like it i thought it was an
ingenious show in a lot of ways who knew
until they sent me some tapes and of
course i saw them with very very clever
writing
wonderful relationships and darling
characters and people you just love and
and i do love them
and we got inside their skins and in
their shoes and
and uh i think we feel very connected
buddy epson
he's a hero of mine buddy epson he's a
hero abraham lincoln and buddy
absolutely well they're both tall
they're both freakishly long legs and
that
appeals to me i'm sorry but uh but but
but uh but when uh but you wouldn't
interpret uh
granny in your own way i'm sure well i
tried to be faithful to the original
old faithful and i did pretty well i
think i am as close as as
a person wants to get or should get i
think i started out with her just right
on target and then you just
do a little extra push push and and when
you do each scene actually you have to
solve
and decide how you're going to do the
scene so right in that
way you can uh solve it in
in a the physical aspect of it in which
we did
right now this is not to be uh you seem
very young to play
to play granny i'm way too young to be
doing it was it is it
it's a lot of makeup it must be
a lot of makeup yeah no now what do you
think about this trend of
uh tv shows look at how i'm sitting
isn't it funny
it's because of what i'm wearing if i
were wearing other clothes
i'd be you know more like this but this
way
i it's more tea party time don't you
like this do you like the chair
i just love it i mean i isn't this a
great chair it's what i'm wearing it's a
velvet and it makes you want to
sit like this do you ever find that when
you wear velvet it makes you want to do
this
i wear i wear velvet underwear on this
you know whenever
i do it makes me constantly feel
comfortable and very sensual
please but when you have a suit on then
you sit up straight
yeah i do sort of sit up straight here
you have to get your legs apart because
it it's just
and do that see and you you have to get
your spray we glued andy's leg like that
he had trouble doing that oh you ruined
it do it again
oh stand up like this there you go oh
all right he can do it he can do it
that's terrific okay everybody we're
gonna have to go away for a second but
we'll be right back
explorers lead to it i didn't want to
ask you this a lot of tv shows have
become movies
it's really hard oh come on what do you
want me to do i'm doing everything i can
all right there are you comfortable this
way better all right
we're going to get this one is what's so
hard see well what if i move forward
more like this
okay thank you so anyway
this is cozy this feels like larry king
so anyway
that's why i'm comfortable oh okay good
i'll get suspenders in five minutes this
whole thing will be flying
no but uh a lot of shows have been a lot
of tv shows are becoming movies now
it's a big trend now is that does that
seem like a healthy trend to you
do you mind it you think it's fine it's
just good fun do i care
do you care trend a trend well yeah of
course you care what if they turn the
the old mary tyler moore show into a
movie and someone else played uh phyllis
and
uh said that they had never seen the
original show and
it could happen and yet and yet they
still called it the mary tyler moore
movie and even though mary tyler moore
wasn't involved it's a very complex
scenario i'm still working on it
i i probably play
i probably play uh betty white's part in
that case
all right they wouldn't let me play my
own part i'm sure they will but knowing
betty she'd play her own part
i could be a friend coming in to visit
and all that
hello everybody good to see you i think
it's fun i really do
all of it and i i'm all for it yeah i
think trends are good
you heard it here first everybody well
they ask us questions that
we who cares i mean i care deeply no i
mean journalists care because or they
have to write something i actually love
all these old shows though i actually do
care about these
i'm the acting part i do the you know we
just get into the part but to say then
to get outside is this a trend here
right well maybe who cares i mean who
cares right
bring on the good movies if it's an old
movie that's going to be good fine if
it's a new movie that's never been done
fine just you know make us feel good
entertain us
affect us right i think this one is a um
luckily a very successful trend
return um it's just it scoops you up
it's a great cast
really my son um i hadn't seen him in a
while he'd been away at school and when
he came home we went to out to dinner to
an italian restaurant and he chose the
wine and
it was really really delicious he knew
what he was doing
and um he he said this this one he just
just jumps up in your lap and puts its
arm around you i said
that's not your line morgan he said no
but i said stats and he says
yeah but the line's still good and it
applies to
the beverly hillbillies it just it just
sit down it's you know you're in
somebody's lap
and we really really have fun well great
you can
you take your grandchildren take your
family and have fun all the way through
well that sounds like we did have a clip
that i know that you wanted to set up
first is that right i love to set up
clips i was born
to set up clips it's pretty
self-explanatory we're in this lovely um
limousine on our way to beverly hills
the clampett family and
i stopped the car for good and sound
reasons
here we go take it away
[Music]
stop the car gesture there's a fresh
kill in the road
can't just leave it there you're right
granny road kill stew sounds mighty good
right now
oh no you don't show them coop i've seen
it first
melbourne call west tech security well i
i'm sure there's enough first off
wow i would not have known that was you
i was like
it looks like a lot of fun um i'm sorry
it's too bad because there actually uh a
bunch of other things i wanted to talk
to you about
okay one thing quick sure oh quick
quickly phyllis
i i i i'm sorry i mean i was a that was
a incredible
one line on phyllis that i want to take
credit for it oh that's the only one
okay well i'm such a fool really phyllis
and mary so
darling and so a a play uh what do you
call it
patronizing so i made up the slide i
said oh mary one time uh some friends
were leaving
and and she uh was heartbroken she would
never see them again long trip they're
gone now
and i'm consoling i say oh mary and i
added this line dear
funny mary like she's such a
but i'm the one who's sort of oh mary
dear funny mary don't you know that all
of life
is just a long trail of leavings
it's a great line for her all right well
listen thank you very much for coming
uh i know you have to leave but thank
you for being here and we'll be right
back
you